how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu and last
night was an absolutely
insane night for us marvel fans disney
had their investors day and they
revealed
so much for the upcoming marvel phase
four slate and of course
phase five the new trailers for phase
four were awesome you can watch them on
my channel i posted them last night but
today we're going to talk about
phase five so let's just jump right into
it and also i'll be announcing the
giveaway winner at the end of this video
and today i'm excited to talk about the
expansion and future of the mcu
as you may know the cinematic universe
weaves story lines and heroes and
villains across
23 feature films to date and with disney
plus
we're able to extend this way of
storytelling to a new format
creating series that are connected to
our theatrical releases
making the mcu more immersive than ever
there's a lot of new content coming from
marvel studios
so let's get started launching on disney
plus later next year
is miss marvel miss marvel is a
pakistani
american teen superhero earlier this
year during shutdown we held online
auditions
all around the world to find our kamala
khan and we found her
in iman vilani aman will be surrounded
by a phenomenal cast and creative team
that will bring this story to life
so here's an early look at miss marvel
miss marvel is a new kind of superhero
but at the core of all of it her story
is so universal
miss marvel is one of the newer
characters in the marvel comics
and when one comes in that grabs the
world's imagination like this
the questions are when are we going to
bring miss marvel to the stream
when miss marvel first came out we had
such an incredible reaction
it was so incredibly popular because
everybody could see themselves in her
i never saw a young teenager of color
specifically a pakistani in
a comic book are you kidding promised
you'd be cool i am cool
the casting process was vast when we
discovered
iman we knew that she was kamala khan
it was unanimous decision yeah i can't
comprehend this right now
and then of course we've got a really
incredible
team of directors
mira menon and charmino beijing and all
of them
are taking the material and elevating it
so
human it's about a teenager figuring out
who she is and
about relationships family and
friendship is at the heart
of the mcu canon that's what's so
exciting about the story that we're
bringing is that we're going to
introduce you to a new family that's
also going to be part of the wider mcu
the fact about miss marvel is that her
idol is captain marvel
and captain marvel too is currently in
the works with director nia de costa
and today i'm excited to announce that
ms marvel played by iman
will be joining brie larson and
co-starring in captain marvel 2
along with a grown-up monica rambo
played by tiana paris whom we will have
already met
in the upcoming wan division so by now
you should start getting a sense of the
interconnectedness
that infuses all of our storytelling but
that doesn't mean
there aren't some unexplored corners of
the universe with next year's eternals
we're introducing a brand new ensemble
of superheroes to the mcu played by a
spectacular cast
this is an epic story spanning thousands
of years and it's one of our most
ambitious
films yet it's set for theatrical
release
on november 5th 2021.
original avenger jeremy renner returns
to star in
hawkeye launching on disney plus late
next year
in our series hawkeye teams up with
another well-known archer from marvel
comics
kate bishop and i'm very pleased to
confirm that kate will be played by the
amazing
haley steinfeld rounding out that cast
are vera formiga
fra fee and newcomer alaqua cox
playing maya lopez the episodes are
being directed by rhys thomas and the
directing duo of burt
and birdie debuting for the first time
in the mcu
she-hulk is coming to disney plus
it's a series about a woman trying to
navigate the world and be taken
seriously as a working professional
despite the fact that she's well over
six foot seven
and green it's a very funny series being
directed by kakoiro
and a new vagia and i can officially
confirm that she-hulk
jennifer walters will be played by the
talented and emmy award-winning
tatiana maslany i'm also pleased to
reveal
that the brilliant tim roth is returning
as the abomination
a character we first introduced to the
mcu in 2008's the incredible hulk
if that's not enough i can confirm that
the hulk himself mark ruffalo
will be appearing in the series as well
and since jennifer walters is a lawyer
who specializes specifically
in superhero oriented legal cases you
never know what marvel characters are
going to pop up
from episode to episode bringing a whole
new different vibe to the mcu
moon knight is an action-adventure
indiana jones type story coming to life
as a disney plus series directed by
muhammad diab
the character moon knight is a complex
vigilante who suffers from
disassociative identity disorder
and these multiple identities that live
inside him are very distinct characters
in the series
the backdrop of our story is incredible
egyptian iconography
egyptology is something the world's
always been fascinated by
and we're going to tap into it in a fun
and bold way in moon knight
now i want to talk about a couple of
projects that we haven't announced yet
the first of which
is secret invasion coming to disney plus
samuel l jackson is back as nick fury
and ben mendelsohn
from captain marvel returns as the
scroll taylos
next to civil war secret invasion is
arguably the biggest crossover comic
event in the last 20 years
and we're bringing it to disney plus
it's about a sect of scrolls who have
infiltrated
every level of life on earth iron heart
will be a series for disney plus about
genius inventor riri williams who has
the most advanced suit of armor
since iron man's dominique thorne will
play the title role
and as we like to do both secret
invasion and iron heart
will tie directly to mcu feature films
we're also well underway on a series for
disney plus based on armor wars
a classic marvel story about tony
stark's worst fear coming true
it's what happens when his tech falls
into the wrong hands
and this series will star beloved member
of the mcu
don cheadle will be returning as jim
rhodes aka
war machine one of the best things about
expanding the mcu to disney plus
is that our team at marvel studios is
finally able to do some of the things
we've always wanted to do
but didn't quite have the right outlet
for like produce
our first ever live action holiday
special
in irreverent guardians fashion the
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
is going to be a lot of fun especially
since james gunn is back
to write and direct in fact we're going
to shoot it during production of
guardians of the galaxy vol
3. this special will drop the holiday
prior to the next guardians of the
galaxy film
which hits theaters in 2023 and speaking
of guardians
aptly titled i am groot everyone's
favorite little tree
baby groot will start a series of shorts
on disney plus
featuring several new and unusual
characters
before i go i couldn't leave you without
giving a few more updates on some of our
most anticipated upcoming films
in january we'll begin filming thor love
and thunder with director taika watiti
and chris hemsworth natalie portman and
tessa thompson returning
and i'm pleased to confirm that academy
award-winning actor christian bale
is playing the villain gore the god
butcher thor love and thunder releases
in theaters on may 6
2022 as we announced the comic con last
year
we're moving ahead with blade starring
academy award winner mahershala ali
the development and story lines are
coming together and we'll have
announcements
very very soon director peyton reed is
hard at work with our marvel studios
team on the third ant-man film
which will officially be called ant-man
and wasp quantum mania
hall rudd evangeline lilly michael
douglas and michelle pfeiffer
are all returning and katherine newton
is joining the cast
and playing cassie lang and in the role
of kang the conqueror
we have a great actor jonathan majors
[Music]
i wanted to acknowledge the devastating
loss of a dear friend and member of the
marvel studios family
chadwick boseman was an immensely
talented actor and an inspirational
individual
who affected all of our lives
professionally and personally
his portrayal of t'challa the black
panther is iconic
and transcends any iteration of the
character in any other medium from
marvel's past
and it's for that reason that we will
not recast the character
however to honor the legacy that chad
helped us build through his portrayal of
the king of wakanda
we want to continue to explore the world
of wakanda
and all of the rich and varied
characters introduced in the first film
writer director ryan coogler is hard at
work on the sequel now and will bring
the film to you in theaters july 8th
2022 and finally
i'm happy to announce a film about one
of the truly iconic marvel families
in fact marvel's first family fantastic
four
we're working on a feature now and it
will be directed by the director of our
recent spider-man films
john watts we've got a lot in store
marvel studios and disney plus is key
to the interconnection and expansion of
the mcu it will be home for both our
feature films and our series
for years and years to come and big
congratulations to youtube user mark
tuttle for being the winner of this
week's zombie mysterio funko pop
provided by heroes hideout.com
email me in the email in my description
and i'll get you your funko and for this
week we're giving away another tony
stark quantum suit
funko pop all you have to do to enter
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below
and everybody be sure to let me know
what you think about phase 5 what is
going to be your favorite project coming
up mine is going to be the fantastic
four
it's about to be really really good for
marvel fans 2020 sucked but
2021 and 2022 are going to be insane so
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof